We start by distributing the 3. So we'll have 3 times 2 for our first term.
We'll add to that three 3 root 7 for our second term. Now that we've
distributed the 3, let's distribute the root 2. We'll have root 2 times 2 for
the third term, and root 2 times root 7 for our fourth term. Next, we multiply
3 times 2, which equals 6, these are multiplied together but we can't really
change anything since this is not inside of a radical. So we just have the 3
times the root of 7. Here we list the number and find the radical so we have 2
times root 2 and finally for this last term we have root 2 times root 7 which
equals to root 14. We can't simplify any of these roots since, these numbers
don't have factors that are perfect squares. Also none of these terms are like
terms. This is just the number, this is root 7, this is root 2 and this is root
14. Remember the radicands and the indexes, must match in order to add radicals
together. So, we just get this lengthy sum of all the terms. That's our final
result.